president biden with covet again testing
positive on saturday after testing
negative for four days prior even before
the second case of covid worries
heightened over the commander-in-chief's
mental capacity and ability to lead
here's dr ben carson on this program
last week calling biden's condition a
national security risk
there's no question you know he's in
that age range that puts him in an
increased risk and he has underlying
problems as well so
it is a serious issue the good thing of
course is he has access to the best
medical care
in the world
at walter reed so i suspect he will get
through it but i hope and pray like many
others that he will recover from that
but that still leaves the
the problems with his
ability to communicate appropriately
not to make gaffes and to create
confidence one of the things a leader is
supposed to do is to create confidence
in those who are following him and we
have exactly the opposite of that and
he's a laughingstock around the world
this is not good for america
and this week senator chuck schumer will
try to amass more support for a new
version of biden's build back better
agenda after getting the support of west
virginia senator joe manchin to spend
additional hundreds of billions of
dollars on biden's climate change a
priority while also raising taxes
joining me right now is a member of
senate leadership he is a wyoming
senator john barrasso senator it's great
to have you this morning thanks so much
for being here
great to be with you maria thank you
so before we get into this new spending
and tax package let me get your thoughts
as a doctor you are a orthopedic surgeon
as well as a leader in the senate your
thoughts on this reinfection with covet
that president biden is facing now
well it's certainly a concern we want
the president to fully recover but we do
know that people who have been
reinfected have higher health risks
going forward health risks of long-term
covet and health risks in terms of heart
lungs even neurologic issues and bigger
problems with fatigue so we hope that
the president doesn't fall into that
category we want him to recover fully
absolutely we are praying for that for
sure let me get your take on the agenda
senator last week your colleague on the
left joe manchin agreed with senator
chuck schumer uh to spend hundreds of
billions of dollars more and raise taxes
to pay for it were you blindsided by
this
well i know joe has been working on this
but let's take a look at what happened
last week we saw economic numbers
continue to come out we saw the
president's poll numbers continue to
fall he's at historic levels he's
pushing for the life alert button
because he's fallen and he can't get up
and the problem with what manchin and
the democrats are proposing here is
the american public is having a hard
time keeping up they just can't do it
you can't afford a full tank of gas you
can't afford a week's worth of groceries
and what manchin and the democrats and
the president are now proposing
are the two cardinal sins that you don't
want to do
when the economy is in such a dire
situation number one is they want to
raise taxes in the middle of a recession
now i know joe biden says it's not a
recession but if you google recession
it's a recession two-thirds of the
american people believe we're in a
recession they're living it the other is
they want to do massive government
spending they have a 725 page bill
and it's over a billion dollars a page
at the time when we're at 40-year high
inflation this is going to make
inflation worse
yeah i want to get your take on this 80
billion dollars to double the number of
irs agents as well but you're mentioning
the 369 billion on energy and climate
efforts only in washington can you come
out with more hundreds of billions of
dollars in spending and call it an
inflation reduction act senator we know
how inflation got stoked we have the
inflation timeline right here consumer
prices are up 9.1 percent uh in the last
reading and they were 1.4 when joe biden
walked into the oval office how is it
possible that
your colleagues are voting for something
that will likely uh make inflation worse
do you believe inflation gets worse as a
result of this
i believe inflation gets worse the
experts who are looking at it
believe experts believe that the
inflation will get worse this is false
advertising by the democrats this is
the last big wish a dying wish of a
party that knows they're going to get
shellacked come november
they have all the spending and the taxes
in this that they've been trying to get
there's no guarantee that it's going to
get passed and we can talk about that in
a second but the things that are in this
look this is the parade of horribles
from last year
they are hiring 86 000 additional irs
agents that's not just to go after a
couple of big companies they're coming
after families farmers small businesses
and what do they want to use the money
for they're going after
energy producers so they can give
subsidies and pay people to buy electric
vehicles these are going to go to rich
people this is going to make the pain at
the pump worse it's going to drive up
inflation and it's going to hurt the
economy even more maria
yeah it's just incredible does it pass i
know that you've got a week
back at work before you go on recess in
the senate what's happening this
upcoming week and how will uh senator
cinema take on this
well you make the important point here
that senator cinema hasn't i know she
felt blindsided by this and she is a
spine of steel she's not going to easily
be twisted the interesting thing is that
joe
joe manchin has bought into this there
are things included in this bill that
last year he called shell games and
smoke and mirrors and accounting
gimmicks
so i'm not sure what chuck schumer
promised him but i think he's going to
regret making this decision to sign on
to this every republican is against it
because we know it is going to burn a
deeper hole into the wallets and the
savings accounts of american people in
terms of will this past they need all 50
democrats on board and in the room maria
and what we know is that due to covid
and due to surgery or some of the
democrat members they haven't had 50
senators show up for work in well over a
month so this is far from done
well i mean i think you make a good
point but if it doesn't pass is it just
pure luck i mean let's face it senator
your colleagues continued to disappoint
on many levels did the republicans get
duped again that's what kim strassel
wrote in the wall street journal this
week i know you saw that op-ed but they
introduced this new version of buildback
better under a new name just hours after
they get the chips bill passed you did
not vote for the chips bill what is
going on with your colleagues handing
the democrats a win when everywhere you
look there is another blow up when you
have a wide open border and they refuse
to acknowledge it what's wrong with your
colleagues
well number one is you know i did not
vote for that bill i thought it spent
too much money and focused on a specific
industry but no i never trusted chuck
schumer i knew he was going to continue
to try to put together some reckless tax
and spending bill to the final moment of
the final day of the fiscal year so i
knew he wasn't going to stop no
republican should ever believe chuck
schumer with regard to the bill that
passed
there are republicans and democrats who
know we have a specific problem with
china i say never again can we be
dependent on china for medicines for
materials
for important minerals never again
they're trying to get it a problem i
just think it didn't provide what we
needed to do to prevent china from from
stealing our trade secrets i've been on
the conference committee for that bill
the votes were there i'm not surprised
it passed what i am surprised is that
the joe manchin has signed on to chuck
schumer's bill i'm not surprised that
chuck schumer will continue to tell
people anything that it will help him go
very very liberal with his agenda
well senator i guess what i'm asking you
is shouldn't the republicans be doing
better at this point look everywhere
whether it's inflation whether it's wide
open border of foreign policy disasters
like afghanistan
china he refuses to call an adversary
only a competitor and look at the
congressional generic ballot and the
congressional vote preference that we
have here democrat 41 percent republican
44 percent shouldn't the gap be wider
shouldn't republicans be winning
and shouldn't it be a a an assumption
that the republicans take over not just
the house but the senate as well why
these numbers in your view
well i'm very optimistic about the
elections in november it's still a
hundred days away maria this is going to
be a rejection election the american
people are going to reject the democrats
and joe biden because of the things that
you just mentioned
crushing inflation chaos at the border
crime in the cities this is a reason to
eliminate and to remove and to defeat
all of the democrats who are on the
ticket we need to take the majorities so
we can stop
this reckless agenda radical agenda that
the democrats have we need to get back
to the job of
building the economy not building the
government which is what the democrats
want to do we take over the senate i'll
be chairman of the energy committee and
we will go ahead
what go ahead now you can take over the
senate i'll be chairman of the energy
committee i'll be chairman of the energy
committee and we will put on joe biden's
desk bills that will actually bring down
the cost of energy by drilling and
getting the permits to do the
infrastructure we'll hold this
administration accountable
real quick i want to get your take on
why your colleagues voted for the chips
act was it because the liberal
universities want more money and and how
do they explain that this administration
wants every accounting and everybody's
account they want to know anytime you
take 600 out of your account or have a
transaction of 600 wasn't that the
proposal in the initial buildback better
well there are a couple of things there
look i have great concerns with china
and this is the new battlefield of the
21st century it's not just weaponry it's
information as china tries to be the
military the the economic and the
technological superpower of the world we
can't stop we have to continue to work
to stop them from allowing that to
happen that's what our focus needs to be
and we have members that have been
working to do that i think this bill
didn't accomplish it the other issue
you're referring to the taxes these
yep i mean in terms of their their
billed back better i mean they're coming
after everybody with raising taxes
that's who they're going after families
and farmers everyone in an effort to pay
for liberal things that i think are
going to make the economy
worse it's going to make inflation worse
deep in a recession these guys look like
what they're doing the democrats are
trying to do is get to double dish
double digit inflation we want to get
inflation down their proposals actually
seem to raise it
senator thank you very much for being
here and for your leadership senator
john barrasso